[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here's just a little bit of will ferrell
introducing me at the radio hall of fame
hi there i am i am extremely honored
uh to speak on behalf of my dear
dear
dear dear friend
dan patrick as we
commemorate his induction into the radio
hall of fame
um
[Music]
dan i'm i'm so proud of you i i told
myself i wouldn't get emotional and uh
i'm not
but
i just know that when use
i just know that when you started out in
your business your one goal
was to get into the radio hall of fame
and gosh darn it
hold on let me compose myself
gosh darn it
you did it dad
it's the radio hall of fame
and no one can ever take that away from
you you know there wasn't a dry eye in
the room in chicago
will ferrell joining us on the program
will thank you for the
very emotional very moving speech uh i
know it came from the heart
it takes me right back as soon as i hear
that sound
it takes me right back i'm proud of you
dan
very proud of you america's proud of you
well
uh i didn't know that it would elicit
that kind of emotion but man uh
wow i mean real tears powerful
and uh
i'm uh
a great emotion to the point where i was
punching holes in the drywall of my
house
uh i couldn't i wasn't able to calm down
for the next hour
well i'm glad that sandler wasn't
available and david spade wasn't
available and some of the other people
that i ask and uh brian cranston and i'm
glad that you did respond so
put me in coach put me in
uh do you have a thought on your alma
mater usc with a head football coach
well i don't want to stir anything up
my inside sources tell me
a gentleman by the name of nick saban
will be the next
coach
okay
dick saban nick saban is going to leave
alabama for usc
nick saban is a mountain climber okay
and he's already reached the top of that
mountain multiple times he's looking for
the next mountain
and that mountain
in los angeles california
um
my inside source okay
okay uh one inside source
but our but you're a booster aren't you
you should have some information
i'm not a booster but uh i
my one inside source that i talk to
i talk to on the hour every hour
is a uh
it's pretty pretty pretty has his finger
on the pulse uh
he's a former player
i don't i don't want to say who it is
but
is it carson palmer
[Laughter]
oh no we can't do you can't do
what
wait wait come on what's going on here
you can't do that to carson palmer he
had a bad week last week we can't do
that to him this week okay oh well he's
my source
i don't wanna
i gotta give credit where credit's due
[Music]
hey how's your career going what's going
on with you
uh it's
an absolute free fall
um
no i well since you asked dan i've got a
a a
limited series coming out
we're out of time right now
the shrink next door me and my good
friend paul rudd
i saw the trailer for it as we like to
say in the business and uh yeah
you got wild-looking hair you got your
glasses on and paul rudd doesn't seem
like he's a good guy in this uh series
no
i transform we both it's uh it's it's
different from what you're gonna
normally see us do it's exciting and
it's called i'm stretching it's
stretching
well hold on what i
the others i'm just getting this too
it's either nick saban
or it's nick saban's brother
one of the two
teddy bears
yeah
yeah he has nothing to do with football
i don't think uh either way
we're looking good
well thank you very much well and uh all
right
all right next hall of fame i'll uh i'll
reach down reach out to you okay
when is when is the next one what do we
think
i mean it it feels like it happens like
uh a couple times a year
yeah
yeah because you're getting you're
getting towards the end you're getting
ready
yeah i'm not in a free fall yet but yeah
i'm getting towards the end
trust me i know the feeling
keep keep your head up okay
i think i'm getting inducted into
nickelodeon kids choice hall of fame
i think well congratulations
that's you got that that you you were
snubbed for years and i'm glad that that
that has been remedied
no let's see if i show up
all right well thank you thank you will
once again that's it all right
thank you that's will ferrell
very emotional
very emotional